er ist corona endgültig vorbei seitdem
der krieg da ist das fragen wir jetzt im
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach bei uns im studio dank auch
ihrer fragen zu hause ihrer zuschauer
fragen und ich fange gleich mal an mit
dem kommentar herr lauterbach von yvonne
müller die schreibt uns liebe b ich bin
so wahnsinnig wütend auf euch auf uns in
dem fall man findet überhaupt keine
schlagzeilen mehr zum corona waren sind
nur noch ukraine also ist nicht so sie
stellen sich heute der korona
sprechstunde hierbei gilt aber natürlich
gibt es ein spannungsverhältnis zwischen
diesen beiden themen erst recht wenn wir
die bilder aus mario pohl derzeit sehen
aus dieser völlig zerbombten völlig
zerstörten stadt in der ost ukraine das
sind drohende aufnahmen von dort lauter
wenn wir solche bilder jetzt jede stunde
immer wieder aufs neue im fernsehen
sehen die brutalität dieses krieges
sehen dieses putin angriffskrieges
können sie verstehen dass der eine oder
andere millionen möglicherweise in
deutschland sagen angesichts solcher
bilder angesichts dieses krieges corona
ist eigentlich nichts mehr was mir angst
macht
das darf man nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen und zunächst mal möchte ich
sagen dass dieser brutale
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg von putin
die berichterstattung verdient
die sie bekommt das ist der bekommt also
das ist tatsächlich also etwas das die
menschen sehen müssen und
was auch medial genau in der offenheit
aufgearbeitet werden muss wie wir es
derzeit zählen das ist schlicht und
ergreifend eine katastrophe die sich in
zeitlupe vor unseren augen abwickelt und
ist
es man kann es nicht beschreiben es
werden ja auch krankenhäuser zerstört es
werden kinder also einrichtungen
zerstört es gibt keine praxis mehr die
noch funktioniert die menschen
versteckten sich dieses grauen muss
dargestellt werden daran können wir
nicht vorbei geht dass das medial so
aufgearbeitet wird wie jetzt das
verstehe ich und daher ist die
berichterstattung mit diesem schwerpunkt
das gibt wollen völlig klar dass das was
auch in unseren köpfen macht man kann
sich ja nicht um 10 krisen gleichzeitig
kümmern und vorhersehen sachen
gleichzeitig angst haben selbst die
renommiertesten psychologen sagen an der
stelle eigentlich kann der mensch sich
nur auf eine angst gleichzeitig
konzentrieren das heißt man blendet
jetzt krone aus corona ist vorbei in dem
moment ja es wird zum teil nicht mehr so
viel berichtet das kann ich auch
verstehen und balkon ist es ja nicht nur
dass man mit der angst haltige arbeiten
darauf dass er sich sogar zahlt sondern
wir müssen halt
aufklären und wir müssen warnen dort wo
angemessen und wir müssen versuchen
regeln zu schaffen die funktionieren und
wir müssen versuchen hilfe zu geben das
ist ja auch andere gründe das habe ich
heute mich wieder den fragen der
zuschauer stellen aber sie hat feste
falsch mit angst zu arbeiten das nicht
falsch mit angst aber das wird mir ja
ständig unterstellt dass noch mehr
häufigste zuschauerfragen ja genau und
das ist ja auch etwas was also von also
ihrem blatt und auch also von ihren
kollegen mir oft also unterstellt wird
aber ich arbeite sticht nicht mit angst
mache
das muss man klar sagen das ist ein
unterschied ob ich mit angst arbeite
oder ob ich mit einer realistischen
einschätzung dessen was passiert also
arbeite ich bin ein beispiel wenn sich
jetzt ein ungeimpfter infiziert und
denkt omikron also 70 jahre alt ist für
mich nicht so gefährlich eine milde
variante dann würde ich erklären das ist
nicht so er hat dann doch ein
erhebliches risiko dass ins krankenhaus
muss da ist er vielleicht schwerer
erkrankt dass er möglicherweise
verstirbt und dass er möglicherweise
werden das überlebt bleiben nicht seine
warnung
und da würde gar keine zweifel gymnasien
ist es wenn man wenn man in der
vergangenheit mit prognosen gearbeitet
hat die weit über das hinaus geschossen
sind was anschließend ein getreuer
eingetreten ist das ist das was
zuschauer immer wieder kritisieren auch
im vorfeld dieser sendung und sagen halt
na ja daran sieht man ja der arbeitet
eilt mit angst der macht der ist ein
panik minister ja aber wenn man erst
erstens also die prognosen die ich
gemacht habe ich habe selbst ganz wenige
modellierungen gemacht und die waren
übers noch nicht mal so schlecht
aber ich beziehe mich meistens auf
modellierungen anderer spezialisten
beispielsweise eine modellierung von kai
nagel oder eine modellierung des robert
koch instituts und wenn diese
modellierung dann also die realität die
später eintritt nicht so komplett
bezahlt weil auch zum teil so maßnahmen
gewirkt habe dann ist es keine angst
mache sondern ich habe mich auf der
grundlage der besten vorliegenden
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse habe ich
eine prognose vorgestellt
aber das ist doch keine angst mache wenn
die prognose dann nachher goslar
lauterbach lassen jetzt einmal sind
jetzt kurz weg gekommen von dem einen
punkt die eine angst und die andere
angst ist das was sie möglicherweise
auch an sich selber feststellen sie
werden krieg schauen auch vermutlich
jeden tag werden sich genau diese bilder
die wir gerade gezeigt haben auch
ständig anschauen auch im kabinett ist
das natürlich thema sie sind selbst
mindestens ja mehr als am rande
betroffen in ihrem ressort von diesem
krieg zum beispiel über die flüchtlings
lage dort das heißt stellen sie das bei
sich selber auch fest eine verschiebung
des interesses der aufmerksamkeit weg
von corona nachfragen zahl also ich bin
ja für die krone bekämpfung zuständig
und wenn ich sehr unaufmerksam würde und
würde mich anderen themen zu stark
widmen das wäre nicht akzeptabel meine
aufgabe ist es nicht der
verteidigungsminister ich bin nicht der
innenminister sondern also ich bin der
gesundheitsminister ich muss dafür
sorgen dass alles was mit diesem krieg
zu tun hat und was gesundheit betrifft
so weit wir das regeln können gut
funktioniert also gott zum beispiel
bekommen die flüchtenden die hier nach
deutschland kommt bekommen die die
medikamente oder sie versorgen die sie
brauchen sofort sind wir in der lage
hilfsmittel medizinisches mittwoch
betäubungsmittel narkosemittels in die
also
zu bringen wo die menschen das bauch und
wald zu menschen zum teil also wird dort
das sind doch schmerzmittel knapp
narkosemitteln betäubungsmittel knapp
das muss rein mario pohl ist alles knapp
beispielsweise tritt bürgermeister sagt
gerade bei uns in der sendung wir leben
hier wie im mittelalter genau aber wir
müssen die medizinischen hilfsgüter die
müssen wir als land bringen das ist
etwas woran ich mitarbeiter wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die ersten und hast du
aus deutschland die helfen wollen dass
sie das auch können entweder in der
ukraine oder in polen in den
anrainerländern dass sie dort helfen
können und schließlich wir fangen auch
jetzt an
menschen die in der ukraine verletzt
worden sind oder verwundet worden sind
in deutschland zu versorgen denn die
ausgeflogen werden zuerst aus der
ostukraine in die westukraine
das nach polen und dann werden die über
so ein system verteilt das kleeblatt
system was wir bei den koffern nämlich
schon genutzt haben da bin ich auch mit
zuständig aber das sind die dinge wo ich
mich konzentrieren was sie listen oder
auch soldaten also darüber möchte ich
hier nicht auf vortragen auf jeden fall
wir helfen wo wir können es werden
menschen ausgeflogen das system beginnt
hier dem ausmaß sind dass jetzt die
ersten oder genau dass er die ersten das
system muss erst mal funktionieren und
was wird dann getestet
also diese ersten tests haben
stattgefunden das wird jetzt mehr werden
und also das heißt es gibt schon
ukrainische verwundete das lassen wir
mal
die hier versorgt wer genau die er
versorgt werden also wir haben das jetzt
also vor ein paar tagen erstmal durch
gezogen dass die ganze kette
funktioniert also aus der west ukraine
polen dann aus polen nach deutschland
verteilt über ein gemeinsames also
lagezentrum von also bund und ländern
und da ist dieses kleeblatt system im
einsatz was wir auch bei der pandemie
gehabt haben bei den kuwait patienten
somit als somit diese vier bereiche da
bin ich auch mit zuständig längst nicht
allein da sind die anderen ministerien
innen mit dem außenministerium die
schwerst verletzte sind das intensiv
lass uns noch mal sie durchstehen
betreuen lassen wir das mal stehen das
sind leute die eine sehr also intensive
versorgung benötigen und die also in
also intensiv medizinische einrichtungen
also verteilt werden müssen und das
läuft jetzt an
das wichtig deutschland liefert nicht
nur waffen warum ist das so geheim ganz
kurz ohne da in die privatsphäre der
menschen eingreift muss erst mal gar
nicht über worden also gar wird ja auch
mehr zeit wird darüber würden auch mehr
berichtet werden aber jetzt läuft der
hier ist erst mal an meine art damit so
etwas umzugehen ist die lassen sie uns
darüber sprechen wenn es wirklich eine
größenordnung also
erreicht hat die es auch wert ist wir
bereiten das jetzt werden das gut
vorbereitet die finanzierung steht dass
er schlicht noch nicht schmücken mit
einem mit der vergleichsweise klein ja
genau das ist also was ich hasse ist zu
sagen dass leute sich mücken mit etwas
was angekündigt ist aber noch nicht
läuft ich will es wirklich also wir
werden darüber zu sprechen ich werde
empfang am morgen beispielsweise fährt
was volle pulle schon läuft stell das
paket ist die eu kommissarin für
gesundheit die wird morgen mein gast an
da gehen wir nach tegel also in das
dortige flüchtlingszentrum jetzt impfen
so gut organisiert hat den impfstoff so
gut besonders also aus meiner sich jetzt
in den letzten monaten eine vorzügliche
arbeit gemacht und arbeite gerne mit ihr
zusammen sie ist also hoch engagiert bei
der also corona bekämpfung und auch bei
der vorbereitung der und mit ihr arbeite
ich eng zusammen sie ist mein gast unser
gast er wir werden also in tegel seien
werden wir also die sache somit
ankündigen was schon läuft nicht
ankündigen was in planung ist okay da
müssen wir sie dann später daran herr
minister gerne